hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a powerful
wedge scratch that the most powerful
wedge in the Harry Potter Universe to
kick things off let me eliminate the
most obvious choices that may have
popped into your minds it's not
Bellatrix it's not McGonagall it's not
Hermione and it's not Molly Weasley in
fact it's none of these more obvious and
prevalent characters this is a character
that's only really mentioned in passing
but also happens to have quite a rich
history that pertains to the story I am
of course talking about Morgana lafay to
kick things off let me just state that
Morgana lafaye is a pseudo-historical
figure that is a character that exists
in pseudo-history a type of purported
History which treats myths Legends sagas
and similar literature as literal truth
but she also exists in Harry Potter
Potter existing inside and outside of
the universe discussed on this channel
I'm going to be discussing both sides of
her character in what feels like many
eons ago but in actual fact was in 2020
I made a video on the famous wizard
Merlin the most powerful wizard in Harry
Potter and as it happens Merlin and
Morgana share a special relationship
both existing as pseudo-historical
figures that are prevalent in both Harry
Potter and Arthurian Legend typically
within Arthurian Legend Morgana lefe is
depicted as a powerful sorceress and
antagonist she's usually portrayed as
the half-sister or sister of King Arthur
and as a leader of a group of
Otherworldly beings known as the fair
folk this is where her connection to
Magic Begins according to Arthurian
Legend the fair folk also known as the
fairies are a group of supernatural
beings that live in the other world
which is separate from The Immortal
World they are often depicted as having
magical powers and they are associated
with nature including the elements of
air water and Earth they are also
associated with the land and are often
portrayed as having a deep connection to
it the fair Focus seen as a
representation of the mysterious and
unknown forces of nature and the power
of the imagination Organa being the
leader of the fairies is particularly
fitting if we consider that her epithet
lafaye actually means the fairy however
something worth considering here is that
this epithet wasn't introduced until
many centuries after morgana's
introduction in literature in fact the
first writer to refer to Morgana as
Morgana lafaye was Thomas Mallory in one
of his works from the 15th century in
some versions of Legends Morgana is
portrayed as a villain who seeks to harm
or kill King Arthur while in other she
is a more complex character with
motivations that are not entirely evil
this aspect of her character is entirely
dependent on Whose accounts we're going
by Morgana lafaye's character has
appeared in many works of literature
including the medieval poem Le Mort de
Artur Mallory's work modern novel The
myths of Avalon and first and foremost
Jeffrey of monmouth's work Vita merlini
or the life of Merlin which was written
in 1150 Visa merlini was a Latin poem
which told the story of Merlin's Madness
his life as a wild man of the woods and
his prophecies and conversations with
his sister in many different Works
Morgana satisfies the role of powerful
sorceress and chief antagonist known for
her beauty and her ability to use magic
to seduce men she is also known for her
enmity towards Merlin and her desire to
kill him usually acting as the main
rival of Merlin and sometimes the one
that is responsible for his death these
texts present Morgana as a powerful and
cunning wedge who uses her beauty and
her magical powers to manipulate and
deceive others within Vita merlini
Morgana is referred to as Morgan a name
which means Seaborn the name survived in
Middle Welsh as morian and the cognate
form in Old Irish is muigen the name of
a shape-shifting female Saint commonly
associated with the sea but the story
and portrayal best known by fans of myth
and Legend relates to morgana's role in
the story of King Arthur Merlin and the
Knights of the Round Table the story
which has been subject to copious
adaptations over the years tells the
tale of King Arthur Pendragon his court
his kingdom and his most trustworthy men
in this story and many others Morgana
was portrayed as the evil sister of
Arthur intent on conquering Camelot this
version of Morgana who came to
prominence through the works of Thomas
Mallory was Arthur's greatest enemy
constantly plotting to usurp his throne
it's also worth mentioning that almost
always Morgana was depicted as
possessing magical powers that rivaled
the great Merlin further cementing her
historical prevalence as a powerful
sorceress now onto Harry Potter we first
hear of Morgana lafaye in the Harry
Potter Universe when Ron mentioned that
he has about six of her chocolate frog
card
I've got Morgana again and I've got
about six of her chocolate frog cards
generally feature iconic witches and
wizards of History to the fact that she
made the cart is a testament to her
prominence as a historical figure even
in the Harry Potter Universe her card
makes it very clear that she was a very
powerful dark witch and this directly
sums up the version of Morgana that the
Harry Potter Universe adopted we got the
evil Morgana not the morally righteous
one this is an important distinction to
make because across many pieces of
literature Morgana is a figure of great
moral ambivalence early appearances of
Morgana do not elaborate her character
Beyond her role as a goddess a fey a
witch or a sorceress generally
benevolent and related to King Arthur as
his magical Savior and protector her
prominence increased over time as did
her moral ambivalence and in some texts
there is an evolutionary transformation
of her to an antagonist provided that
her card describes her as a very
powerful wedge I think that it's
reasonable to assume that Morgana was
extremely versed in the dark arts
possessing knowledge of all of the dark
spells that we are accustomed to and
perhaps many more if she was the
adversary of Merlin the most powerful
wizard to have ever lived I imagine she
must have had a few tricks up her sleeve
in Arthurian Legend Morgana is said to
possess a wide range of magical
abilities she is known to be skilled in
the art of healing and is often depicted
as a powerful herbalist and healer
typically healing and the ability to
heal are paired with individuals
associated with moral goodness or
righteousness and so I felt it
noteworthy to mention that Morgana
entirely contradicts this
she is also known to possess the ability
to shapeshift and is said to be able to
take on the form of animals birds and
other creatures from the sounds of it
Morgana was probably one of the first if
not the first animagus that is a Witcher
wizard that is able to transform into an
animal at will however the noteworthy
exception here is that Morgana was able
to transform into a multitude of
creatures not just one a testament to
her exceptional magical ability
additionally she is said to have been
able to control the elements possessing
the power to summon storms and control
the winds Elemental Magic is very much
prevalent in Harry Potter but for the
most part appears to be reserved for the
most powerful witches and wizards people
like Voldemort and Dumbledore the best
example of Elemental Magic on display in
totality was during Voldemort and
Dumbledore's duel inside the ministry
Atrium she is also known to be able to
teleport and transport herself and
others over long distances did that
sound like an ability in Harry Potter to
you that's right Morgana knew Apparition
but the vast list of magical abilities
that Morgana possessed that have been
boasted about by copious pieces of
literature certainly don't stop there
according to other Legends She was known
to have been able to create Illusions
legilimency create magical barriers
protego and even create portals to other
dimensions the veil it's unclear what
powers Morgana may have possessed inside
of the Harry Potter universe as the
powers attributed to her differ from
story to story but I feel that if she
truly was the Nemesis of Merlin who was
widely considered to be the most
powerful wizard I'd expect she had the
capability to perform all of the above
and that's it for this video did you
guys know about Morgana already if so
what did you know about her got any
questions let me know down in the
comments section below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live